Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
So
as you can see I'm a floaty head
today. Steve is doing the same. We're gonna
have a little bit of fun with some
infrastructure as code.
Now before we get started and I introduce
Steve, I would encourage you please subscribe and
click the bell on YouTube so you get
notifications of more awesome episodes
and also you'll notice that on most of
the scenes we're using today there as a
discuss
discord embed
which discord have currently got broken and you'll
see your name as object object but I'm
hoping they fix soon. So please feel free
to join us in the discord chat.
And now I would like to introduce Steve.
Steve Wade, an independent consultant and active member
of Kubernetes and get up communities. Hey, man.
How's it going?
Hey. I'm good. How are you?
Yeah.
I'm very well. I'm looking forward to what
we're gonna be kicking the tires on today,
having a bit of fun and and generally
just chatting gets up in automation.
Yes. It's it's gonna be good. Right? We've
we had that question that someone was posting
on Twitter, and now we're gonna give a
demo of a possible way to fix it.
So everyone everyone's the winner, and you're showing
me some new technologies that I've never used.
So
Yeah. Mean, I guess if I was smart,
would probably have had that tweet ready in
advanced and been able to show on the
screen but I am not. So we'll talk
about the prompt space as we tackle them
together.
Why don't we give a quick
summary of what we wanna do? Why don't
you go first and then I'll try and
add in anything else that I think is
interesting.
Sure. So the the plan here is to
essentially start from scratch
and look at how we can bootstrap infrastructure
and also enable deployments
straight out of the gate for your workloads
that are running within Kubernetes.
So, essentially, we're we're starting with that bootstrapping
problem. So that initial cluster up
plus
how we hook that into a number of
other repositories in in this scenario, it's gonna
be one
so that we can start to bootstrap workloads.
So this is a common problem that, you
know, everyone that's creating Kubernetes clusters may or
may not have, but in a kind of
GitOps paradigm where you wanna drive everything from
Git,
having that initial bootstrapping
from Git is really the way that we
wanna go. That's gonna be the gold standard.
Nice. Perfect.
Alright. Well,
before we get started, let's tackle a couple
of comments. So
our friend
Duffy has left us a message.
Set the bar high there mate but we
do appreciate the support.
Yeah, no question now.
Simon, hey man, how's it going? Alright.
So
what we're gonna do is we're trying, we're
gonna try and split this into like two
stages basically. Mean, you've already kind of covered
us but I'm gonna summarize it for my
own sanity here but what we we're gonna
use Pulumi today. Now we're doing a skill
swap here essentially right like I don't think
you've ever used Pulumi before you're not familiar
with it So I'm gonna try and impart
my Pulumi knowledge on you
and we're gonna do that to get the
cluster
up and running and I'm gonna cheat and
I'm only gonna deploy a cane cluster and
the interest of speed today. I mean, we
don't wanna be spelling up that we don't
want to be spinning up multiple nodes. We
just really, that's not the interesting part, the
code, the automation, the process is the interesting
part
and then we're gonna flip it over and
then you're gonna be driving forward and showing
us how to adopt flux and get ups
and apply all of that stuff to our
cluster and we should have a trade
tight feedback loop by the end of this
and that we can just push changes to
the get repository
and automatically see that all deployed in our
cluster.
That's the plan. Right. Good.
I like it where we're on the same
page. So let's just get started then. There's
no point in messing around. So I
have fought a repository that you sent me
earlier. This is
a get ups example that I think you've
got that uses customize.
Is there if anyone wants to take a
look at it, play with it, etcetera.
But first we need to get some machines
running.
We have a shared Versus code terminal. I
can type, Steve can type too hopefully.
Say hello. There we go.
Guest user. Wow, you're not even logged in.
Okay.
And we have an empty
perimeter entry. We have nothing here whatsoever and
we have that same repository that I have
fought here.
So step one,
as we're gonna create a new Pulumi project.
I'm gonna walk through the process, explain the
decisions that I'm making as I go.
Just prod me with questions. Anything that I've
not explained or whatever, you know, fire to
me. And of course, if you're watching at
home, please use either
the discord chat or the YouTube comments to
throw your questions and we'll do our best
to tackle them as we go.
And it would probably help if I made
the discord chat visible. There we go. Hey,
Duffy's joined us there too. Nice. Okay.
Let's see if I can work out this
Pulumi thing. So if I remember correctly, we
could do a Pulumi new and it's got
like this nice little CLI based wizard that
runs a certain new project.
Now one of the questions I always get
from people is why am I using Pulumi
and why am I not using terraform?
Really I should have queued up for you
to ask me that right but doesn't matter.
That my
go to question. Okay
so there are a couple of reasons I
really like Pulumi,
one of them is I get to use
my programming language of choice and I think
that is super valuable
and you know as much as we,
we want our infrastructure provision and to be
a simple API where I just say give
me a machine as it generally we're doing
a little bit more with that and having
a programming language available for loops and filters
and maps etcetera
gets really handy.
The other really secret amazing just not secret,
the other really super awesome thing about using
the real programming language is that I can
then take common bits of logic through them
and encapsulate them in a function and then
we use it. I do that all the
time
and you know I'm just gonna keep throwing
more reasons out because they're popping into my
head but Pulumi also has the ability to
like wrap terraform providers as well so you
don't really lose any functionality by using Pulumi.
If there's a terraform provider out there, you
can generate the Pulumi wrapper that allows you
to consume it as well, which is great.
And there's that wonderful discord bug where object
objects is now talking. So So is is
there a is there a kind of command
that will allow you to be able to
take a existing provider and and wrap it?
Is that built into the Pulumi
CLI?
It's not built into the Pulumi CLI
unfortunately.
There is let me just pull it up.
Right? This is the wonderful thing about the
Internet. Everything is a few clicks away.
So there is a tf
something.
Oh yeah, so there's a few projects here
that's probably worth mentioning.
There's a tf to Pulumi so you can
actually generate Pulumi code from Terraform
HCL then
there's the provider boilerplate so this is the
repository that allows you you'd basically just fork
this and then tell it the Terraform provider
and then do some Go code and it
generates all the bits and pieces that you
need and it kind of just works.
I'm sure I'm oversimplifying it, it does take
a little bit of effort but it does
pay back handsomely.
Alright,
so today we are gonna do
I've forgotten who I work for. Sorry. Equinix
metal. So yeah Equinix metal is in this
weird stage where the providers always called packet
and we've not renamed everything yet to Equinix
metal because obviously that's really tough to rename
packages that are being openly available for so
long. So what I'm actually gonna do is
just create a very generic TypeScript one and
then I'll I'll drop in the Equinix metal
provider.
Okay, so project name we'll call this
get ops not high ops
description I'm not fussed about and I realized
I've made a mistake already.
Pulumi login local.
Let me explain this too. So
Pulumi and Terraform both have state files, Hopefully
I don't need to kind of explain that
to anyone like when you create resources it
has some
state that understands what resources were created, what
condition they're in and how to reconcile them.
Pulumi provides a managed service much like HashiCorp
do where they can store the state for
you and handle locking and you know our
back and stuff like that for today I'm
not gonna use that so that's why I'm
just doing a login local
and
I'm gonna then just recreate my project
and then now I've got a non empty
thing so
off to a crack and start.
This is how every project starts. Right? You
know, the initial bootstrapping, that's what we're talking
about.
Exactly.
So text script,
get ops.
Yes.
My stack name,
we're just gonna go straight into production
and
because
another really cool thing about Pulumi is it
enables get ops by default and that it
already
ships web secret support.
So when I provide a password here, this
is actually gonna be used because I'm in
Pulumi local mode,
gonna be used to encrypt all the secrets
that we store inside of the repository.
If I was just in
Pulumi
cloud,
sorry they call it Pulumi teams
or if I had another cloud provider like
AWS, GCP or Azure available or even vault,
I can use those as KMS
instead of a password here but those all
take time to configure and we're doing this
the hacky way today. So
password
something
probably shouldn't say that out.
Anyway.
Unless it's actually the word something.
No it was not that it was password
and then
wasn't one two three, wasn't four five six
or seven eight nine you know, I'm not
that much of a cowboy but it's close.
So let's see what we're dealing with now.
We
have a Pulumi. Yaml that describes our Pulumi
project.
We have a stack file,
so Pulumi has stacks much like Terraform, this
is our production stack file, this is where
we can store a configuration and secrets for
that stack.
We also have an index dot TS which
was generated for its upfront which just pulls
on the Pulumi module, now I can begin
to create Pulumi resources.
So is this stack in this regards kind
of like a module in Terraform or is
it a is it an encapsulation of many
modules?
Can you say that again?
So in
in Pulumi world is a stack.
Does a stack equal a module in Terraform,
or does it equal the
execution of one or more modules that kind
of come together before create
your infrastructure or whatever that thing is that
you're trying to
configure?
Yeah. So a stacks like an environment dev
station production, it can consume multiple modules, multiple
Terraform modules, multiple multiple Pulumi modules, etcetera.
And Paul's corrected me. Paul works. That's the
one I was looking for. Yeah.
Terraform has work species. I'm just so embedded
in the Pulumi way of life now that
I don't even remember how to Terraform to
be fair. Anyway,
we also have a couple more. So we
got a hello heritage.
Don't know why Duffy is in RimRath.
I don't know if that's important but
Let's get back to it. See if I
can remember how to Pulumi now. Now the
first thing and I'm glad Paul's watching because
I do this in every stack and it's
so annoying.
I don't want my code
to be an index. Ts in my root
project right? I know user go developers but
it's
messy so I always move it into a
source folder and update the Pulumi. Yaml to
tell it that the main file lives in
there and it's such this is one of
those wee small things that always create something
in every new project.
That's my mild rant done.
So
now we're in position, in fact we could
probably just run
pulumi up with nothing
good someone's at my door, my dog is
going wild but I'm sure someone else will
handle it.
And we can let go
and this is just creating a stack, there's
no resources and nothing for it to actually
do here.
It's all good.
So let's make it do something.
What we wanted to know is add a
provider.
So when we created a project, all we
selected was TypeScript. We never told any providers
that we actually want access to.
So we can
come to
type metal
and this is the
Equinix metal polymer provider.
And I am just going to copy.
I don't even know if I have yarn
or NPM installed
and I don't wanna create a next dot
shell so we're just gonna hope.
Yeah, NPM looks green there so I think
we're okay. So I'm gonna add the provider.
The next thing I need to do is
get my
off token
which is also just in the docs here
and I'm not really doing anything
magic here but we have to provide us
so that knows how to speak with the
API.
Now I'll show adding the secret to our
stack through the galaxy fashion but obviously I'm
not going to show you my API token.
So I'm gonna jump over to my other
monitor
and see a Pulumi
token.
Alright. So because we got secrets management
here we can do Pulumi config
set
secret
Equinix metal
off token and that should just match what
we have here.
Yep. I don't think I've messed that up.
We can hit return.
I should be able to paste this in
and we need the password so that gets
encrypted correctly.
So does Pulumi not preset your password that
you set the first time when we started
the local?
Do you have to add it every time?
So I can export it to my shell
Yeah. Which would avoid me typing it every
time but
yeah, it's not a big deal. Like, I
don't mind typing it. It's
it's not too bad. So
what does that look like in our stack
file? Well,
we can open this up and we can
see here we have some secure value,
which is our encrypted
Equinix metal off token.
If we look at our package dot JSON,
we have our Equinix metal provider.
So
what changes read me TS config should be
alright.
So now we're gonna write some preliminary code,
let's actually spin up a device.
So this is TypeScript,
the reason I like using this is it's
really easy to
kinda get strict types that I can pass
around and functions and you know get some
sort of safety guarantees but at the same
time working with JSON is not as painful
as as we go.
We're gonna create a new
I said how day?
I I really like go for some things
right but
juggling JSON or any kind of structured config
is not as strong so
I hear you. Yeah.
I've forgotten how to code. Oh yeah. We
need to import our provider.
So let's get import as metal from,
we pull in our provider.
I can now do a new metal
device
see and again nice auto complete here.
I've never really had successful auto complete on
Golang to be fair
but that's a rant for another day. So
this is our get ops machine
and that takes a device args, I have
no idea what device args is yet, so
I'm just gonna pop open
an empty JSON object and then trust the
IO complete to lead me through this. So
bell and cycle
will be
Bell and Cycle and all the types are
here as well. This is another reason I
really like the TypeScript SDK.
It's just all there like I'm,
I'm not actually coding, I'm really just all
completing my way through this.
Really suck if my boss found out I
can't actually code so I'm
just gonna speed up a little bit because
it's not particularly exciting.
Let's see.
Throw in all these required fields.
C three medium should be alright hopefully. Project
ID we don't have yet, so we can
talk about config.
What else do I need?
User data.
Alright.
So that's
pretty much it. I'm gonna tweak the last
few things as I talk about them. So
first of all we've got this thing called
a project ID.
So what we actually want here is maybe
something that we would want to configure at
the stack level.
Excuse me. Like we may want to deploy
production to a different Equinix metal project
than we would our staging environment etcetera.
So let me pull up the Equinix metal
console.
Hopefully it logged me into the right one.
Yep. There's my Rawkode project. I don't know
if there's anything here. No, we're good. Okay.
And I'm gonna copy this project ID.
Now because I want this to be configurable,
I'm gonna do a config set.
It's not a secret so I don't need
to pass in the secret thing here. I'm
just gonna call this project ID.
And
all this does is drop it in here
it uses our Pulumi project get ops as
a prefix
to you know providers use their own key
here
and one of the things I also really
like about Pulumi and I won't spend,
don't want to shell it too much right
but it's really cool
is that these take arbitrary objects as well
like you know I could just do like
metal,
I could have my project ID here,
I could have my instant size,
I could really make all of this configurable
and then just load this object as a
single type inside of Pulumi but
don't need to do that right So
we've got a question from Paul,
he's asking why is the person from Pulumi
asking me a question about why I have
Pulumi? I guess it's good to understand why
users do things. Okay so why set the
value rather than making a request to look
up the project?
Yeah. That's a really good point. The
reason I don't do it is what what
Paul is suggesting is that I could do
project name
and just put Rawkode and then actually do
a lookup using the SDK to get the
ID rather than the store an ID to
me they're much the same and so I
just avoid a network quest.
That's it. No real brain or reason to
be fair.
Okay, so now we need to get our
project ID here, so what we need to
do is first get a config
from the Pulumi object
and
then we can define a
type,
so we'll call this my
config
and it's gonna have a project ID
which is a string
and
no, I didn't use an object. Sorry. That's
what I normally do. I'm just gonna do
project ID.
This is the pressure, that's what it is
and that's just a required
field.
So I can say my project ID is
what I want, nice and simple. You'll see
if we take a look at the config
thing here,
you know there's gets for things that are
optional, there's require billions like if I want
to do some sort of type enforcement,
there's require object if I am doing something
a bit more advanced and then there's secret
helpers too. So So can can you do
can you do a get and it works
out in the background if it's a secret
or not not a secret? Or do you
have to explicitly pass the get command if
like do you have to pass get secret
if you're
hoping to return a secret or you're looking
up a secret or can you just use
the generic get?
No. I I,
you know, I've never tried it but I
don't think it would work.
Maybe if Paul's watching, Paul's still watching he
can answer.
Okay, so we have our project ID here
now, project ID now so we can just
drop that in.
We want a host name so I'm just
gonna call this get ops, it's not very
interesting
and then the way that we provision the
machine is gonna be through user data here.
So we're, we're just gonna hack this today
because it's not the most exciting thing.
So I'm literally just gonna do
run a script
grab
my favorite helper of all time.
Get Docker.
Io.
I preferred it when they gave you the
pipe to shell version but whatever.
And then we will run
get docker.
So that will install docker.
We then need kind.
Docker kind Kubernetes.
I'm assuming I just need to grab the
release from the GitHub page actually
unless it's got something here.
So Paul was saying that you can use
git
but ideally you use git secret and they're
gonna change that now.
Nice. I'll pop that on the screen.
Okay. So we can on Linux copy this
and we're gonna need to keep control.
Yep.
And this is of course not the best
way to be doing any of this.
This is just to keep things moving at
a sensible pace this afternoon so
you can imagine really what this would be
doing is like
because I'm
yes.
Thank you William.
There we go.
I've got everybody's telling me now so William
you were first you you can win bragging
rates and then no results so quickly in
as well. So yeah, trim off the script
we run it. I'm gonna pull down control.
I'm not sure where that's putting it.
Probably just the local directory.
So we'll probably want to
move that. And
then kind which does this, I never even
noticed that path that was wild. Okay.
Was about to tell you we need to
change that.
Yeah. Now there's something I want to kind
of explain here before we go any further
like I'm just using user data to install
Docker and install Kube control and install Kine
so that we can get across a cluster
and then I'm gonna run Kine cluster create
and just
that is not what we would normally be
doing in a production environment
and normally you'd be using a managed Kubernetes
or a cluster API or anything else that
provides
better ways to do this but again those
are not the focus for today. So
kind
cluster.
Done.
Are we are we confident that's gonna work?
Do we want a couple of of actual
nodes in our kind cluster
or do we wanna go with just a
single node?
We can just go with one I think,
like we're not deploying anything to Wales to
it, right? So Let's do it. Alright. So
I'm happy with that, you can see we've
got Pulumi, we're using TypeScript.
I'll just kinda show off again my favorite
feature is that this could be in a
library that I consume for NPM.
This could be a create
kind cluster
thing
that as a function
that returns this object
and I could then use
create kind cluster
and I think that just on itself is
a really really good reason for using Pulumi
over terraform.
You're you're selling it to me now.
Yeah, it's just those weird things really. Oh
yeah, I can take these four different resources,
group them together and provide an abstraction that's
just create the thing and nobody else has
to worry about it. I can end up
in types to pass in as parameters to
tweak the configuration and of course you can
go down a rabbit hole and start getting
the abstractions wrong and too much configuration and
making it a bit of a spaghetti monster
but
still very cool.
Anyway,
sorry I digress.
So I'm gonna run a Pulumi up and
what we're gonna see here is it's gonna
try and work out what it wants to
create and then hopefully we get a plan
that we're happy with and we can approve
it.
So Pulumi app is can you do a
Pulumi plan or an equivalent of just the
plan or do you always do an app
and the plan happens regardless?
There's a Pulumi preview command as well. Alright.
So we can see here it wants to
create a new device.
In fact, one thing I will do then
is do a preview and we can also
specify a def.
So we'll we'll actually see the user data
and a whole bunch of other things.
Yep.
Good comment from Paul as well,
very new feature in Pulumi is that you
can write these abstractions in these libraries publish
them in TypeScript or go or Python or
.net and then consume them from any of
those languages too. So even like Steve, could
write a go library for creating kind customers
on Equinix metal and I and my TypeScript
thing could still use that which I think
is really cool. That's nice.
Alright, this is a resource we're gonna try
and spin up a c three medium and
Amsterdam Six and hopefully get a cane cluster
out of it. So I'm just gonna
go for that and hope for the best.
And now we wait.
The chat is is really kicking off object
object is having a party to themselves there.
It's weird like you can hide it and
then bring it back and like the names
work.
So
Bala asked in the Discord chat on local
does it store secrets on a file or
some DB?
I'm pretty sure Paul will be able to
answer that much better than I.
So one of the things Pulumi does is
in my local home directory. I
wonder if we can just take a look
at that quickly.
Pulumi
and we have all of our stacks
and we'll see my production one, we've got
this like JSON and I don't know what
the ATTRs is. I'm not even sure.
Won't guess but all of our encryption information
or secrets are all kind of stuffed in
there and you can use KMS,
you can use
vault and you can use Pulumi teams which
is a bit secure but
you know as I think what's just really
cool is that
I mean I could just store a big
long password and one password and distribute it
to my team and I can still commit
all this to get and it's secure like
you know it's a really quick way to
get started to bring and get
platform side rather than just the application
workload side.
Objects is object is awesome.
All the same we need to approve. Clean
me up. Did. I did. Did. It's running.
Yeah. I left it sitting there for too
long and I noticed it. I don't think
anyone noticed but obviously
Paul's keeping me honest here.
Alright. Well, spinning up some bare metal on
Echorus metal takes
about ninety seconds to hopefully two minutes worst
case. Oh did I use a fast provision?
What what I've been to today is?
Alright,
it may take four minutes. I should have
used a bunch of 24 but still we'll
we'll we'll get some at the end and
I think just for the sake of today
if you're alright with that Steve like if
if I don't get a Kain cluster I'll
probably just manually SSHN and create it
so we can move on to the next
step but I'm
confident our user data that's I mean that's
some pretty solid IP there I think we
could sell that.
Quite like being a floating head especially when
I'm
got code behind me.
Yeah. Hold on. You have to review my
code for me.
How's it look?
Problem there.
Let's see.
Pulumi Pulumi.
I guess we can go over to my
dashboard.
Yeah. We can see our Gallup's device here.
We can actually just click on the table
in. Okay. So it was pretty quick.
We're just the servers being rebooted. We're just
waiting for it to dial in. Probably
find I'm getting pretty close to being able
to
SSH into that. Not
quite.
So there's one other thing.
We we we have a cane cluster, we've
not deployed a flux to or anything yet.
No. I can do that manually or I
can show off a really cool feature of
Pulumi and I'm trying to decide what I
wanna do.
I'll talk If
if we're trying to bootstrap properly,
then then that's let's use the tools for
the job. So
if I if I if I were if
I was gonna bootstrap
the
the cluster,
I would in in in Terraform world, which
I'm familiar with, we deploy
flux using that. So it's it's standing up
the cluster plus the initial bootstracking process.
And it relate to you.
Alright. We'll do it properly. We do have
this as itch. So let's see when are
we.
Silly me.
Okay.
Docker container.
Why did I not get my cluster?
Oh, it's not cluster create. Oh, it's create
cluster. Alright.
So let's just do that. We'll fix it
here.
So when we push the code it works
and we'll blame the chat because they should
have been all over that.
Yeah and we never chimaudied our acute control.
Nice, okay.
Now it's definitely a million dollar script.
So what I'm gonna do then so that
we can still use Pulumi to apply flux
to our cluster
as I'm gonna actually just grab the cube
config from this machine store it in the
Pulumi
config
and then
use it and the provider.
Yeah. Okay. We have a working. Okay.
Much better. Okay.
Now we did also change the user data.
I don't wanna force the device to change
on me.
I'm actually gonna revert these changes and I
will fix it before I push the code
to the Internet.
I promise.
And the reason why is that I wanna
be able to run Pulumi
preview dev
after I've added the cube.
What?
How dare you?
Did I break it? What have I done?
I
can't use ignore changes, so Paul suggested I
can just say ignored. Oh, I can't do
that on the actual resource, that's a kill
feature. He is a legend.
Sorry I did to you. Okay.
Make my changes again and you know you
can tell me why Pulumi is telling me
my password is incorrect if you've a minute
to me.
Chimaud plus x user Ben cube control.
Okay.
That
doesn't help me does it?
That is a known bug I am working
on as we speak. How do I fix
it for just now?
I'll wait.
I'm gonna export my secret so hold on
see that helps. Well I'm just gonna move
this window over here.
Yeah, he's told me I need to just
export. Yeah. Oh
and I tried the wrong tab. Okay. Let's
go back. So export.
Pulumi config
passphrase
equals.
Alright.
I mean it's not even a real password.
I don't know why I'm going through so
much effort to.
Okay.
So let's see.
Preview.
Now if I do a deaf now.
Yeah. Paul's told me to, no, I'm just
gonna export to Paul because even though it's
not a real password,
there was a blob visible in my production
dot YAML that if they had the password
they could maybe correct with that salt
be a lot of effort but I'm still
not gonna do it. So we can see
that with my fixes this wants to recreate
this device. I do not want to do
that and as Paul
reminded
me is that after our device RX we
have some Pulumi RX
one
of the really cool things you can do
there is just tell it to ignore changes.
String.
Am I not using that right?
Ignore changes to any of the specified properties.
Yeah. So user
data.
So
hopefully when I run deaf now, it doesn't
want to change this resource and then we
can bring in that cube config and user
data with a capital D.
No, no changes.
Don't
ever use that flag. Thanks.
It was very special use case. So now
I'm gonna grab this cube config.
Run it locally.
Where does kind store that I can do
kind
how do I get the cube configs on
this, do you know?
Is it is it kind
plastic conflict?
Yeah.
Okay.
If anyone wants to take that out and
have access to a cane cluster for the
next area, you're more than welcome.
I shouldn't say that Duffy's probably got some
OCR running already that does it.
Okay. So what am I gonna do? I
am gonna store this
as a secret
called cube config
config set.
Woah. No. That didn't work.
No.
Let's base encode it. Base 64.
I broke it.
Yeah. That that looks like half of it.
Okay.
Copy.
Who just thought I got stuck on the
cube config. Alright. There we go.
Is that it? Yeah.
Yeah. That's it.
Okay. So let's do
cat
cube
cube config.
Pipe that into a Pulumi config set secret
kube config
and
hope that just put the dash on this
will do what I want.
Looks promising.
Success.
Oh, you have three of the same thing,
but
Try that again.
That can't be big enough for me. That
can't be big enough. Right? Right.
You know what? I'm not gonna store it
as a secret.
It's not a big deal, it doesn't matter.
Let's just do
get ups
and just store it as a multi
liner.
Yeah.
That's alright. Yeah.
That'll do.
Okay.
So
let's get me finished in the next few
minutes. So we need one more Pulumi provider,
which is the Kubernetes one.
Which I'm sure I could just have done
NPM install with roughly the same thing.
This gives us access to the Kubernetes thing.
I'm gonna create a custom provider with my
cube. Now this last five minutes is obviously
the hacky approach where I'm trying to make
it work. If you were using Pulumi it
has been up JKE or EKS you would
already have access to a cube config through
programmatic means.
I was just trying to speed things up
and probably slow them down a little bit,
but still.
So now we can import our Kubernetes provider.
I just called Kate.
We go down here. We're going to create
a Kubernetes provider.
Give it a name Kubernetes.
It should take a cube config as a
resource
and I'm going to do config dot require
cube config
and that should give me a Kubernetes provider
that I can apply a resource to.
So we're gonna be using flux one today.
Is that correct?
That's correct. Yeah. Flux one.
Alright.
So long story short is that I didn't
have enough time to actually rework the whole
entire repository over to Flux two.
So maybe we should do this again once
I've done that.
Sounds good to me. I think Noel's trying
to ruin my day today.
Your Cane cluster won't be available on the
internet. So
let's try.
Alright. Maybe we will be doing this manually.
Docker. Is it actually published in the port?
It only banks to 12700.
Right. Yeah.
Is that something I can change?
Let's just do it from here. Yeah. Let's
just apply flux one. So I'll show you
what this would have looked like. I'm sorry
that I can't show you it for real
but we could have done
flux
v one equals new Kubernetes deployment.
Core,
no apps.
V
two
deployment.
Give it a name.
And then when we open up the braces
here, we have access to all of the
spec,
the
template,
etcetera. Right. So you can flesh out your
Kubernetes spec this way. Another really cool thing
you can do is do a new Kubernetes
dot yaml dot config file,
give it a name,
point it to a
fail
which actually accepts remote locations
and so you can apply remote yaml.
One last thing you can do is you
can do helm charts v three chart,
give it a name
and then provide all the details and the
values here too.
So like there's so much flexibility with the
Kubernetes provider that allows you to do everything
that you need to do as well.
Alright. Let's just do it manually.
So flux one, I just grabbed that from
So what we what we could do is
the majority of the scripts are actually in
the repo. So if we if you're if
the repository that you thought that you thought
was
is public,
we can climb that whole repo onto the
machine.
Okay.
No give us a good idea here. Instead
of using kind I should have used case
three d or case yes. That's actually a
really good point.
That would have been much better.
I'm
learning, learning
much. So
let's install git.
Git clone. So this is
SSH URL.
Alright. What do you want me to run
here?
So there's a script inside the scripts directory.
There's a flux in it. So if you
run the flux ah, yeah. We're gonna need
help. So of course.
With all these little things we don't think
about.
Install.
Quick start.
Just give me a
curl out there.
Oh, there's a you spelled your mark wrong.
Oh, of course.
Get her You can get that from the
main flux repo. So flux c d slash
flux.
Give me a curl version.
Alright. Release it.
There we go. Oh, wait. Yeah. Flux one
two. Okay.
Linux.
No.
No. I don't know what.
I know what you think. I think it's
okay. I think it's fine. I've got
we're we're we've got one more release left
on us before that stops working.
Yeah. It's just installing the helm operator now.
So we'll give that a few seconds.
Okay. Cool. So, yeah, that's your Bitlab deploy
key. So for for anyone that doesn't really
understand how this process works, essentially, we're gonna
do is Flux is the agent that's running
inside of our client cluster.
We're gonna have a repository that is gonna
store essentially the definitions
of the manifests and the resources that we
want to deploy into the cluster. So we
have to use this deploy key as a
way for flux to be able to talk
to that repository.
So I just need to add this to
this get ops repository then?
Yes, please. Apply keys.
Go
demo.
Do we need to Yeah.
Yeah. Do that. Click that.
Alright.
Cool. If you go back to the script
now.
And just hit the button?
It it will wait. And as soon as
it's seen that it's able to get connectivity,
it will continue.
Alright. So while we give that a second,
I'm just gonna make sure you've got
SSH ability via the shared terminal.
Oh,
come on computer.
Seems to be
happy with me today.
Alright. So you should be able to
modify that repository which we have open here.
You've also got a terminal.
Let's check on the status.
How often does it check?
It hit enter. It should it should have
checked by now.
Oh, which repository is that using? It's using
yours. Right? Yeah. We haven't made we haven't
made the changes.
There we go.
Easy fix.
It's not gonna change the deploy key, is
it?
It
essentially, we're about to find out.
I guess it's the best for everybody. Right?
Don't just copy random random repairs off the
Internet and expect them to work first time
for you.
Oh,
Waleed has joined us. Hey, Wally.
Hi, Wally.
Who says he's getting TGIK episode deja vu.
Alright. It looks like the cluster is now
ready.
Cool. So now if you do
kubectl
get pods
Feel free to type in the terminal. Why
don't you take over?
I cannot edit unless I sign in. Okay.
Bear with me two seconds.
I can see we've got the helm operator
running
and we have a flux namespace.
Oh, my alias doesn't doesn't exist here.
We should run-in flux, memcached and
op editor.
Oh, you have joined. Let me give you
access to that terminal.
Done.
All yours.
You may wanna alias keep control to key.
Do you use that alias? No. Yeah. I
yeah. I do. But I'm gonna get myself
so confused if I do that.
So
yes. So get
pods.
So, again, got the default Helm operator in
the default namespace, and then as you showed,
the dash n Flux here.
So
we have when we deploy Flux, Flux comes
as two main components. We've got the actual
Flux agent itself that is gonna sit there
and interact and
reconcile our repository, and then we have a
Flux mem cached pod that you can see
here, which is actually gonna store or is
used to store all of your image tags.
So
imagine you're doing continuous deployment,
and you what we don't wanna do is
have to constantly keep updating
our specifications
in Git. We want a way to be
able to configure that once,
check that into
our Git repository,
and then essentially have Flux be able to
determine
and look at the image registry for new
image tags,
automate the deploy of those image tags, and
then the kind of secret sources are already
writing it back to Git. So Git is
our centralized source of truth here for the
workloads that are running within the cluster.
Nice. And then
kind of Flux's
kind of right hand man essentially
is the the Helm operator, and the job
of the Helm operator is
to
manage the life cycle of Helm releases.
So with Flux, you have this a resource
in Kubernetes called the Helm release.
And, essentially, what that is
is a Helm chart at a specific version
with a specific set of values.
So rather than you kind of in the
old world having
a home chart and different values dot YAML
files, so you may have had, like, dev
values dot YAML and staging values dot YAML.
You essentially can define all of that as
a single resource
that can then be committed to Git.
Flux will sync that. Flux doesn't have the
understanding of knowing what to do with it.
It's just being used as a sync mechanism.
And then the Helm operator itself
will pick that up and actually be able
to reconcile that. So the Helm operator is
doing the Helm upgrades, the Helm installs, the
Helm rollbacks, the Helm deletes, and Flux is
just actually being used as syncing those into
the cluster.
Does that make sense to everybody?
Yeah. That sounds good.
Let's see the magic.
Can you guys see me expanding out the
the terminal there?
No. But I can expand to that. That's
okay.
Okay.
So if we take a look at sorry.
Not the terminal. The
the the repository on the on the right
hand side of the directories.
Let me follow you.
Right? Now anything you do, we will see.
Cool. Okay. So
with regards to
how Flux is configured, especially specifically for this
repository,
we
are using
customize. So the way that customize works is
essentially you have a base,
and the base is really how I like
to think about it is an a la
carte menu
of multiple resources
that can be used
within a specific cluster or within multiple in
multiple clusters.
So here, all we're talking about is the
the development cluster.
So that we have a development cluster,
and then that is going to inherit
resources that currently sit within the base configuration.
So the base configuration is gonna store all
of the resources
without the environment specific configuration. So think of
things like URLs
or maybe an API an API token or
something that we're gonna deploy as a secret.
Those are the diffs. So the diffs sit
in your environment directory,
and a large majority of your majority of
your of your YAMLs essentially sits in base.
So if we take an example,
so inside base,
we have
cluster.
And, again, inside cluster, we have a a
namespace here.
So we can see the namespace in this
example is called a demo.
And then if we expand out into
into the dev directory
underneath cluster, you'll see that there's this customization.
And for this customization, what we're doing is
we're going back up to the base directory,
and we are gonna in we're gonna basically
consume everything
within that cluster directory.
So this allows us to be able to
put a large majority of our configuration in
base,
reference to that configuration within our environment
specific configuration,
and then have the ability to be able
to override
certain portions of that. So the best example
really here is gonna be for our
pod info.
So pod info, again, has a namespace
with the name pod info, pretty self explanatory.
And then we have a helm release here.
So this is a definition of a helm
release.
So the helm release is saying we
gonna give it a name. So name being
pod info. We're gonna deploy it to the
namespace pod info.
We have a chart,
and Stefan has provided us a nice
chart registry there
that we can use at a specific version.
So here it can be
can be a reference to git if we
wanted to. It doesn't have to be a
URL. It can even be local.
And then a release name. So this release
name is a release name for
the specific
instantiation
of this
helm release.
So this name needs to be unique at
the cluster scope. So one of the things
that I'll kind of come on to is
the CI portion of this. This is one
thing you wanna guard against. So what we
don't wanna do is be deploying the same
multiple different helm releases
with the same helm release name. We really
wanna be keeping these things unique.
And then finally, the values file. So this
is your kind of common
dev dash values dot YAML. And all this
is doing is going to take
the default values that are in the pod
info helm chart and then override with with
this one here. So what we're saying is
for any base configuration configuration in any environment,
we want to deploy
this version of the Helm chart
with this tag.
The way that kind of all gets bundled
together is via a customization.
So the customization here is saying,
for this specific customization, we want to add
these two specific resources. So we wanna add
the namespace, and we want to add the
helm release.
And then when flux actually gets hooked in,
it essentially traverses the tree from bottom up.
So if we go back to the dev
directory,
you'll see here that there is a Flux
customization
a customization, sorry, in the dev directory,
and this points to all of the other
directories within
this top level directory for the environment.
So we can see here actually, I'm gonna
kind of gloss over pod info.
In our Helm releases directory, again, we're just
going up to
the top level Helm releases directory because we
don't need to keep repeating the same configuration.
We're always gonna be deploying a Helm operator
the same way in every environment. Otherwise, this
is not gonna be able to be reconciled.
And then, again, the same thing with the
customization for the cluster. So all we're doing
here is essentially building up the overall makeup
of
our of our environment.
So
now what we have is and what I've
shown you is simply just
a a kind of rinse and repeat. Right?
It's a copy. It's an exact copy of
base. But now what do we wanna do,
or how can we make changes
to base that are specific to our environment?
And the way that works is by leveraging
something called a a customized
patch.
So in pod info here,
you'll see we have a customization again, and
we are taking a resource,
and that resource is that top level declaration
that we have in our base directory.
And then we are gonna perform strategic merge.
And we're gonna take this strategic merge from
the Helm release YAML in the same directory.
And our Helm release YAML
looks like this.
So what we could do if we wanted
to is change this to six.
Right? And imagine we had a lot of
configuration in base. All it will do is
it will blend what's in base with what
we've got in here, perform the strategic merge,
and then what flux will do is deploy
the exact same chart but just with a
different tag.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. It does.
Sounds good.
So
because this is already checked into Git,
we've actually already deployed this. So if we
go back to the terminal
and
the kubectl
get pods dash n pod info,
you'll see here that we've already got pod
info deployed.
This is where auto complete is gonna kill
me.
Yeah. It's annoying when you don't have your
tools in front of your normal workstation tools
available.
You actually have to remember commands and stuff.
Can I copy it?
Yeah. I think you're about right.
Okay. So what we can see here is
that,
actually, we've gone to version four dot zero
dot six.
However,
at no point in this
declaration
have we ever specified the version four dot
zero dot six.
Even in our dev directory, we have specified
the version four dot zero dot three.
However, if you remember before, I said we
need a way of being able to do
continuous deployment.
So I made a a major assumption that
Stefan is already doing work whilst we're recording
this
and has created us a new image.
And we use this flux annotation.
So
like everything in Kubernetes, we have this concept
of annotations,
and we are gonna set the Flux automation
to true. So once we set this value
to true,
we are telling Flux
that every
every time
you perform a sync with our registry,
can you go and look for new image
tags
that match
the prefix or the semantic version that we
have set below?
So you can set this in flux five
minutes, ten minutes, fifteen minutes, one minute. It
doesn't matter. And every time it goes and
looks at the registry,
it will see if there's a new version.
It will
deploy that version for us, and then finally,
will write it back to Git.
Here is the slight difference between
using customize as the way of
implementing this and just kind of having a
load of YAML files that you don't use
customize on.
So what you'll see here is there's a
flux patch directory
sorry, a flux patch file within the dev
directory.
And now this is saying, okay. Well,
the flux patch has specified that the image
tag
for this Helm release
has gone to four dot zero dot six.
So when you're looking for diffs between environments,
you're not just looking
at the YAML files. You're also looking at
the flux patches as well. If you weren't
using
customize,
it would actually make the changes to the
YAML files directly,
and you would we would just be able
to go straight to to here and actually
see the fact that there's a change to
six.
That make sense?
Uh-huh.
They're just two different ways of being able
to see it.
So
I don't think I can commit easily from
here to your repository.
Why don't I drive you through making a
couple of changes and we can actually see
this in action?
Yeah. Of course.
Alright. So
go ahead. What's first?
So let's start with something very basic. Let's
just create a namespace.
So
we have multiple options here. We could add
the namespace to base or we could add
the namespace just
to our dev cluster.
It feels to me that we should maybe
add it to the base.
Yeah. So we could add it to base
and then inherit it in our
our dev cluster. Definitely. Let's do So I
can just call this the Rawkode namespace.
I'm just kinda copying what you already have
anyway in the demo one.
And then
namespace.
It's a meta data or spec for namespace.
I can never remember.
I think it's meta data.
I think that's valid. Let me let me
check your demo one.
API version.
I should know better. That was poor.
Metadata name. Yeah. I'm good. There we go.
Okay. So
key thing to note here is that you've
just created a namespace. Now we need to
create a customization that actually inherits that namespace.
But because
you've added it to the namespaces directory,
where we need to add that file is
customization that sits under the namespaces directory. So
stay where you are, and then underneath your
namespace dot YAML, you'll see that customization dot
YAML. Yep.
Now we need to we need to add
your namespace to here.
Now could I just do namespaces
star star star or do I need to
very explicitly say Rawkode?
Let let's try it and actually we can
we can run a test script locally and
actually see what gets rendered.
I'm
just gonna do that. That that may be
right.
Okay.
And now because so you've made that to
base. Right? And if we go to the
dev directory and we look at cluster, if
you expand the cluster definition
and you look at this one, we inherit
everything
from cluster. So you can naturally you're gonna
get this.
So now if you go back to your
console,
you should
be able to run make
and then
yeah. You need to
and then test dash dev.
Am I gonna need flux control?
Nope.
Okay. So this is basically saying that it
doesn't I don't think it Yeah. Don't think
it like that. So I'll do the I'm
gonna try a few more because I'm feeling
brave.
Okay.
I'm not gonna do that then.
Namespaces
Rawkode
namespace.
Yeah. Cool. Okay. Let's try that again. Yeah.
Much happier now. There we go. That's better.
Okay. So then now if in your directory,
if you go to there then there'll be
an underscore test.
I don't know if you wanna show it
in Versus Code.
Perfect.
So you can see that if you now
look for for Rawkode,
you should be able to see
the namespace got added.
So if we now commit that to git,
we're gonna need to do kind of two
we probably want two split terminals here because
what we're gonna wanna do is do a
get namespaces and have it in a watch,
and then you're gonna wanna commit.
Okay. So get namespace watch
and then we're gonna pop over here. So
what what's the
how often I'm assuming that flux isn't pulling
GitHub every one second. Like, what's the what's
the Alright. So we we've configured it now
to be I think we've configured it now
to be about every every minute or every
couple of minutes.
Get Pesh. I always type that.
Alright.
So that's the way
we pop over here,
and we wait for the the magic to
happen.
Yeah. So what we probably should show what
we can show is the logs from Flux.
So if we go and get the Flux
pod logs, we can actually see the fact
of exactly what it's gonna do in the
background.
Okay. Flux get pods.
Nice.
Log slash f.
What's the timestamp I've So what you're seeing
is the old if you see here on
the your line there, you've got the old
Git shard and the new Git shard.
So it's now seeing a new a new
Git shard there.
So, yeah, where you are there. So you're
gonna see the old one and then the
new one. So so
Flux is obviously gone. It's constantly reconciling Git.
So the key thing to note is that,
again,
flux and well, kube Kubernetes in general is
eventually consistent, but flux is also
eventually consistent.
So we're gonna have to go around this
loop possibly a few times for us to
be able to actually
sync that
namespace.
Alright. Okay. So it's just not seen the
namespace yet. Is that? It's not seen any.
Alright. Guess we'd see something here. Yeah. I'm
seeing a lot of unchanged so far so
we just have to
make sure I pushed it properly and actually
left. Right? Yeah. Okay. That's okay.
See if I can see it on GitHub.
Alright. So we added this and we got
this. Cool.
And this is definitely using our dev overlay.
Can we confirm that?
Yep.
If you go to
do a cube CTL describe deployment and then
check the flux deployment.
Oh, gotcha.
Flux describe
deploy flux.
And what were we looking for here? We're
looking for the
branch configuration.
Scroll stay where you want. Yeah. So git
git branch master.
Ah,
are you pushing to master or are you
pushing to main?
Oh, you must be pushing to master. Otherwise,
it wouldn't have sunk. I pushed to master.
Yeah.
Okay.
I would have expected to have kinda seen
the names. Yeah. I would have expected to
do it for now as well.
So I got something wrong. Let's let's call
it that. What did I get wrong then?
Go back to the flux logs.
Of course.
So we can actually I guess we can
verify the commit shot here. Right? So Yeah.
This is saying that it pulled 52CF
which oh, it actually is my commit.
Yeah. So what we also did as well
is that we did the we did a
test
which essentially
showed us what flux was going to reconcile.
That's interesting.
Why? Is this a valid
namespace?
Maybe I have to test that That looks
valid to me.
Where is this split? Let's just be sure.
Rawkode.
API
version kind.
Oh, that got capital n.
Oh, yeah. That might do. Metadata name.
Yeah. I wonder if that's it. I wonder
if it's really just
you think you would get an error message
in the Flux logs. Yeah. That's that's not
a resource.
Fix.
Don't be a dummy.
There we go.
I always do that. So annoying. Anyway,
let's push. Let's jump back over here
and I'm so confident that this one is
gonna work.
I would just give that sixty seconds.
Yeah. Small end. That was still the other.
Hopefully, was it.
This is why if we were doing if
we were doing a PR properly, alright, we'd
we'd catch it with CI.
So one of the things we probably do
wanna show is whilst we're waiting for this
is if you go to
the
the circle CI directory,
we can actually show some of the CI
that is done or could be done to
this
to this repository.
Okay.
So using a there we go. Rawkode. There
we go. Ta da.
The Told you it was my fault. It's
always my fault. So,
obviously,
what you did was a prime example of
why we want to be using some mechanisms
that we have available to us in gits
to stop those kind of things from happening.
Right? We don't want someone to accidentally
merge something to master,
and we end up breaking the whole entire
cluster. That's not ideal. So
in terms of tooling that I would recommend
people leverage
to stop this from these kind of things
from happening, there are a number of tools.
So the first one is is kubectl. And,
actually, if we executed kubectl, kubectl would have
told us that that was not a valid
YAML file and would have stopped us from
being able to merge it. Yep.
So that's the first one that we have.
So that's just doing strict
validation against the upstream
JSON schema.
Check for duplicate Helm releases.
Again, that's what we talked about earlier about
how your Helm release names, you don't want
them to clash. So this is just checking
for duplication.
Deprecates check. So,
obviously,
as everybody knows, Kubernetes loves to deprecate APIs
to click at one sixteen.
So what this is doing is it runs
in the background a set of Reggo policies.
So Reggo policies think Open Policy Agent,
uses conf test as a kind of command
line tool to be able to run those,
and we'll run those against the output
of a
customized build. So when they would run
make test dev, what he as actually running
behind the scenes is customized build pointing at
the dev directory.
And it will run all the Reggo policies
against all the outputs
and then validate that you're not using any
deprecated APIs.
So these are kind of the top top
level ones to stop us from, you know,
making slightly silly mistakes.
But the main one
that we really wanna talk about is is
HR Vowel. So if you noticed, we were
deploying Helm releases.
Right? So so doing KubeVowel
and doing some contest against that, not really
that useful in the in the grand scheme
of things because the Helm chart is actually
what's what contains
the raw YAML files. So what we really
wanna be doing is validating the output of
them or essentially what the Helm operator is
going to be deploying.
So what HR Vowel does is it takes
a combination of
obtaining the Helm chart at the at the
version that you've specified,
passing in a mixture of the default values
and the values that you've specified in your
Helm release,
performing a Helm template. So Helm template is
just gonna spit all of that out,
all of the raw YAMLs for that Helm
release out into
into the console
and then runs kubectl against them because those
are the actual things that we're deploying. The
Helm release is just a wrapper.
What we wanna be doing is actually validating
the inside,
the kind of the, you know, the the
meat and potatoes of the Helm chart, not
assuming that the Helm chart is gonna deploy.
And then the the final one is is
one
that I've added because it catches me every
single time,
which is the customization specification is so specific
that what you want is something that tells
you that you've made a mistake before
you give it to Flux to tell you.
So there's a customized edit
fix, which essentially its job is to tell
you that you've either misspelled something in your
customization dot YAML or you're not conforming to
the recommended way of doing it.
So
release the order of having releases and then
patches,
etcetera, etcetera. They are very they have very
specific standards.
So having that is gonna make your life
more easier by the time Flux gets it
and can't actually
execute the customized build.
And if you scroll down, I think that
that's possibly it.
Yep. Yep. And then we just put them
all together. So there, all we're doing again
with CI is just getting more confidence
that before
Flux actually syncs the repository,
it's gonna be able to deal with what
we gave it.
Yeah. But I was making up my wildcard
syntax. I probably should have run this one.
So that's really cool.
I I like the way that works.
I like, you know, the way we can
compose those layers together with the bases and
the dev and stuff like that and you
know, there's something running in my cluster containers
with pillow chase using apply them like,
get up to Rawkode. Yeah.
So
I think the the great thing about this,
right, is let's let's assume that we didn't
have to manually SSH into the cluster. We
didn't have to run a couple of commands.
And what we did is we had a
really nice way of bootstrapping the cluster
with flux,
with a SSH key or a deploy key
pointing at the right directory.
We just run Pulumi up, and the whole
cluster just bootstraps itself.
Right. And then after
x minutes,
we come back
and the whole cluster's there, all the
all the workloads are there, all the services,
all the ingress, everything. Right? But let's then
take it one step further and go, actually,
do you know what? By accident, I run
I don't know what the equivalent of Terraform
destroyers. I'm assuming probably Pulumi down or something
like that.
We run the equivalent of Pulumi down because
I did it by complete accident.
I just run Pulumi up again, and I
get back to exactly where I was the
last time the cluster sunk because everything is
stored in Git. Right? And if I want
to
take dev and create staging,
I take my lovely Pulumi config.
I change the word dev to stage
and make the changes in the staging directory
and I just run Pulumi up and I've
got a staging environment.
Well, I I feel like you were calling
me out here and saying that it would
have been nice if the bit that I
did actually worked and I I know
that it's harsh but you're right
and what I will do you know obviously
we're not gonna have time to do this
this afternoon I am gonna swap out the
user data to do a KCS cluster which
will be exposed to the internet
I will dynamically get the cube config and
I will install flux and I'll put I
would just push this as an example of
a way to do it so that people
can see it.
So why don't we just is there sorry.
Is there anything else you wanna cover or
should we just jump into like a summary
of of what we put together?
No. That that's yeah. Let's jump into a
summary. Make sure that we've answered answered everybody's
questions that they have. Yeah. Please if you
if you have questions drop them into the
chat or into the discord, we'll tackle them
just now before we finish up. But you
know, the two pieces of the system that
we're I think we're kind of drawing a
line in the sand here, right? What we're
saying is that you need automation
something like Terraform or Pulumi that does the
platform provisioning aspect.
And then we have the flux which is
the workload provision aspect and if you can
really get them working together,
you have that ability in a single command
to spin up an entire environment.
But because we weren't using a kind of
managed Kubernetes or like cluster API, a real
way to spin up a bare metal cluster
because I thought it would be quicker.
We didn't have that programmatic access to a
cube config which is unfortunate because we could
have deployed flux and a nice shiny fashion.
That would have handed over to your flux
pulling on the manifest using customize and the
bases deploying the workloads and all of that
would have been amazing demo of just pulling
me up,
boom, work.
I I I think what we're trying to
say right is that
a lot of with with a specifically a
GitOps paradigm, we want everything in Git. That's
the kind of, you know, the golden standard
here. So
what we don't wanna be doing is pushing
a lot of code or a lot of
YAML files or manifests into the Kubernetes cluster.
We want the absolute bare minimum, and the
bare minimum is gonna be flux pointing at
our repository at a given directory.
And then all of the config that you
need gets sunk into
the cluster. So it's not it's it's a
very small push based model because you're gonna
have to push some initial configuration, but then
there is a massive pull based model as
well.
And I think the the one thing that
you and I were actually going back on
Twitter talking about
was
Flux can upgrade itself. So Flux can upgrade
Flux. So you can have a Flux in
your Pulumi config, and you can have a
corresponding Flux in your Flux repository.
Yep. And you could start your cluster with,
you know, Flux one dot five,
but then in your repository,
have one dot six, and it would constantly
keep itself upgraded.
So that initial push,
you're not bothered about after Pulumi up has
has completed
because all of your life cycle now is
done in that repository.
And you're back to git, you're back to
CI, and you're back to all of the
PR process, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera. And you're driving
everything from from there. Yeah. Definitely.
Hey, Marky.
Good to see you. Hope you are.
Alright.
I'll give people just, I guess, thirty more
seconds, please. If you have questions, let's let's
get them in.
Thank you for joining me today. It was
really good to actually sit down with you
and have a proper conversation and pair on
something that we've not done that before.
It's been very, it's it's always you and
I going back and forth on Twitter and
it's been really pretty good to sit down
and I've learned loads. Right? I've never I've
looked at Pulumi from the outside. I'm I'm
so kind of head in Terraform land because
that's kind of what I'm what I'm familiar
with. And actually seeing
the the power of Pulumi and some of
the things that actually
Terraform doesn't do very nicely, and Pulumi's got
that obstruction and how that can fit into
the current workflow of, you know, just hooking
in some some manifests and getting them to
reconcile. Like, I think it's great. The the
the bootstrapping mechanism is there whether you choose
Pulumi, whether you choose Terraform, or whether you
choose any other
infrastructure as code tool. But the the pieces
of the puzzle are there. Stop. Get the
cluster up, get a Flux instance, and away
you go. You're you're ready to reconcile and
start to deploy workloads.
Yes. Definitely. I
I just can't see past Pulumi anymore. I've
just been using it too long, I understand
you know it's got some weird things in
it of course all software does but I
know I've got over the hump there and
I just when I go back to TerraForm
or I try to we have Terraform modules
for Equinix Medal and when I go to
try and contribute to them I'm just like
I feel like I've actually traveled back in
time like the Stone Age or something I
find the tool is working against me and
I used to love Terraform and it's still
a great tool I just I don't know
I struggle with it now and it's my
thing and not not a bad thing about
the tool.
Guess just because we have a few minutes
and you know you're a very knowledgeable person
why don't we just talk about get ups
then? Like Sure. What are the big changes
with flux v two? Have you been keeping
an eye on that?
So I think with with flux v two,
if you if you think about flux
or the flux agent, it was doing a
lot of stuff. Right? It it it was
looking for new images from its from the
image registries.
It was syncing repositories.
And what Flux v two is doing is
essentially splitting out
and decoupling these things into into smaller agents
or smaller controllers.
So there's an image controller. There's a customized
controller.
There's a
Helm operator that they've called Helm controller. So
they're decoupling them,
and
they're they're moving much more to a model
whereby you can declare absolutely everything with their
configuration.
So think about you've got a fleet of
clusters. In this scenario, we've just got a
single cluster. Yeah. So how do you define
a fleet when you do when you stand
up one of those clusters within that fleet?
What's it gonna be reconciling?
And the overall observability of flux v two
is is generally incredible compared to compared to
flux v one, knowing we wouldn't be able
to go to a dashboard and see that
that sync wasn't being successful as an example.
So a lot of the kind of griping
pains that people had with flux v one
is being fixed in flux v two,
and they're essentially decoupling it. So that is,
unfortunately slightly more YAML files that you do
have to get your head around,
but
you you have a tighter control over what
each of those things does. And,
yeah, I think that's I think that's a
really powerful mechanism.
Alright let me throw another question at you
then like,
is there ever a reason you shouldn't use
GetOps?
Because I think you've
sold me on it, I see this incredible
power and flexibility and continuous delivery, but as
there as there anyone is watching, they should
be like, oh, I shouldn't be doing this.
Is there any of those gotchas that people
should be aware of?
I I think
it it comes down to firstly
understanding
the mech like Kubernetes as a as a
as an orchestrator.
Right? You there is a lot of power
there just from what Kubernetes is doing itself.
And if you have already got a load
of pipelines that push your code or push
your helm charts
into Kubernetes,
actually pulling that out and putting it into
GitOps
could be very, very painful. Right? There could
there could be so much logic that's in
those pipelines
that developers or engineers may or may not
fully grasp. They just hope it works or,
you know, they haven't they haven't looked at
it for for a long time. Yeah.
Maybe maybe that's not necessarily
move the best way to move to to.
But I think for me, it's not about
the syncing.
It's about two things. One is using the
tools that every developer knows how to use,
which is Git, understands PRs, understands
CI. Then
also the ability to to some degree, and
I'm gonna caveat this with, obviously, of a
number of caveats here.
You can start to move to seeing your
cluster as ephemeral
because the cluster is just is just a
way to deploy workloads, and it it always
to some degree has.
But if we can, like we were talking
about earlier, remove
or destroy the cluster, re spin it back
up, and reconcile everything from a known state.
That is extremely powerful.
Obviously, you've got storage that you have to
deal with, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera. So those there
there comes the caveats, and Yep. I'm definitely
not gonna talk about CloudMated storage.
But also as well,
I think the other useful thing is you
have an audit trail of changes. I don't
have to troll the CI pipelines and work
out how far things got through. I have
an audit trail of all the changes. So
if you're working in a financial or regulatory
industry like I am with insurance,
I can show the order to all the
changes that happened at any point in time.
I don't have to collate this lovely spreadsheet
that they love to see. I just show
them the commit history of our, you know,
our x number of repositories that we have.
Awesome.
Alright.
I could easily keep you here for another
hour but I'm gonna let you get back
to your evening. I'm sure it's late where
we are so thank
you very much for joining me. I had
a lot of fun. I hope we do
this again with more stuff. I
hope that people watching enjoy themselves as well.
Steve's Twitter handle is there under his head
sway1987
give him a follow he is always tweeting
on
awesome stuff on get ups and I also
see him answering so many questions from people
as well like so if you need help
I'm sure he'd be more than happy for
you to reach out and he'll do his
best and of course you can reach out
to me I'm just not as useful. So
Steve have a great evening, thank you for
joining me, will speak to you again soon.
You too, it's a pleasure. Thanks. Thanks. Bye.